the problem with this victim culture
right now
is they're rewarding the people that
shouldn't be rewarded and we have to use
language to coddle them to make them
feel like so that now they're not fat or
obese they're customers of size of of
what size I have a size two it's just a
size two or four not the reality is you
should be paying double your fat ass is
sitting in two seats pay double but now
you want to give them two free seats
what it's like you remember when the
people with like now we're going to be
doing a people who have have horrible
credit scores and have been laid on
their bills we're going to give them a
better mortgage price than the people
who actually have good credit scores
that have been paying all their bills on
time it's backwards it's illogical no
wonder people where do I sign up for
that